but often when we start to dig deeper
into very mundane things like coffee for
example which is something we drink
basically every day we start to realize
that very basic things are strongly
connected to religious
Traditions the history and origins of
coffee is strongly intimately connected
with Islamic mysticism or
Sufism tea in a similar way would not
have spread to our part of the world if
it wasn't for the Buddhist monks and
their mystical practices as well so the
next time you sit there in the morning
with your regular cup of coffee maybe
remember that the whole reason you're
having that experience is thanks to
Muslim Mystics and their devotional
religious
practices I'll see you next time